this episode was made possible by
generous supporters on patreon
hey crazies quantum mechanics is weird
the concepts are so alien to us which I
think adds to their appeal if we're
being honest though I kind of hate
quantum but what I hate even more are
the myths people develop about it
I know people still have them because I
keep getting comments like this so let's
set the record straight myth number one
sometimes electrons behave like
particles sometimes they behave like
waves
it's called wave particle duality false
before you freak out
let me explain first we have to be
careful with the word particle a
particle is vaguely defined as a small
portion of matter which is always true
for things like electrons protons and
neutrons no matter what their behavior
they are always small portions of matter
so they are always particles that's why
we call all of these things elementary
particles but the particle and wave
particle duality is saying much more
than that
it implies that those small portions of
matter those electrons protons and
neutrons also exhibit exactly the same
behavior as normal objects for clarity
let's call this an object instead of a
particle from now on that means we'll
call it wave object duality instead
second the justification for this idea
usually comes from the double slit
experiment which I'm really tired of
hearing about and I'm sure you are too
so here's the quick version say you've
got two walls but the one in front has
two openings if you launch a bunch of
paintballs at the first wall a pattern
develops on the second wall we'll call
this pattern object behavior if you do
the same experiment with sound you get a
very different pattern will call this
wave behavior it's a way for us to know
if a small thing is an object or a wave
but it gets weird when we do this
experiment with microscopic things like
electrons if we only detect the
electrons at the second wall we see wave
behavior if we detect the electrons at
both walls we see object behavior it
would appear that what quantum particles
are depend
the circumstances but that's not
actually the case
electrons protons and neutrons are
always particles but are never truly
objects but didn't the experiment just
Chenault no it didn't
yes we sometimes get patterns like this
for particles but we have to be careful
about what we think that means the
double slit experiment doesn't tell us
that particles behave two different ways
it tells us that our ordinary notions of
behavior are wrong quantum particles do
not have wave object duality
they are never objects they are always
waves quantum particles only behave one
way their way what you gonna do about it
Punk
myth number two when particles are
measured they stop obeying quantum
mechanics and start obeying classical
mechanics huh no while it is true that a
wavefunction collapses after a
measurement you're misinterpreting the
word collapse what you're thinking is I
can actually address this by expounding
on something I said during the last myth
quantum particles are never objects they
are always waves so they're always
governed by quantum mechanics hmm an
example might help here's the wave
function for an electron in a very
simple box you can see it could be just
about anywhere in the box
if we'd like the electron to have a more
definite location we need to measure it
the easiest way to do that is with a
photon the interaction with the photon
changes the wave function that change is
called a collapse now the electron is
here if we can't forget the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle it says we can't
ever measure any property exactly most
people are familiar with the one
relating position and momentum these are
typically called uncertainties but
that's a terrible name they're actually
standard deviations because quantum is
all about probability what's the
standard deviation okay okay okay
here's a crash course in statistics for
example school exams are scored from
zero to 100% traditionally those scores
are distributed something like this
with the mean average right in the
middle the standard deviation tells us
something about the spread of the scores
roughly 68% of them should be within one
standard deviation of the average
roughly 95 percent within two standard
deviations and so on it gives us an idea
of the width of the curve the same kind
of thing happens with a quantum wave
function this position here is just an
average it's not exact the standard
deviation is not zero and just like with
the exam scores it gives you an idea of
the spread or whiff of this curve came
to narrow this down some more yes you
can make the standard deviation smaller
but never zero the higher the energy of
the photon the more localized you can
make the electron but these two standard
deviations for position and momentum
multiplied must be greater than this
number so neither one of them can be
zero on top of that the more definite
you make the position the less definite
you make the momentum in other words the
less wavy you make the position the more
wavy you make the momentum and all
properties of a particle are related
like this in one way or another
you can't escape quantum mechanics myth
number three reality only exists because
conscious observers exist all right look
I understand how easy this misconception
is to come to I have the same
misconception a long time ago it's also
philosophically interesting but it's
simply not true
reality would exist whether we exist or
not the universe does not require human
beings it does not require a conscious
mind it does not require life this
electron didn't change from this wave
into this wave because a person was
looking it changed because it interacted
with a photon the human experimenter was
an unnecessary part of that event the
same goes for the double slit experiment
the experimenter is unnecessary all that
matters is the interaction particles
interacted with each other
long before life evolved in this
universe and they will continue to do so
long after life goes extinct so let's
recap one quantum particles do not have
wave object do allottee they are never
objects they are always waves
to quantum particles always obey quantum
mechanics and three quantum mechanics
does not require conscious observers
stop jumping to conclusions if you have
any questions about quantum mechanics
please ask in the comments thanks for
liking and sharing this video don't
forget to subscribe if you'd like to
keep up with us
and until next time remember it's okay
to be a little crazy so I said
doobly-doo in the last video and some of
you were like oh my god you stole that
from so it's show for the record
everyone stole that from Luisi
you know this guy anyway crazies thanks
for watching
[Music]